bonjour je m'appelle alexia je suis
coach de vie et en formation pour
devenir sophrologue
le coaching de vie prend compte
l'intégralité de votre corps physique
mental émotionnel et la sophrologie vous
aident à lâcher prise au niveau du
mental grâce à des exercices de
respiration de mouvements doux et de
visualisation positive
allez on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le principal c'est vraiment de gainer le
ventre les abdos en partant vraiment du
périnée devrait monter de rentrer tout
l'intérieur de serre et les fessiers et
d'un garde est vraiment un alignement de
la cuisse le dos et la tête et vraiment
cet angle de 90° au niveau du genou font
hélas vous cliquer en avant comme si
vous poussiez une portant donc là voilà
vous faites ce mouvement une dizaine de
fois en gardons bien l' équilibre en
gardant bien la ceinture abdominale
serré donc le but
vous partez sur les coûts non vous
guinée vraiment levante les ados les
cuisses en vous serrez vous êtes ferme
dans les épaules vous êtes vraiment
alignés et vous qu'est né au maximum
tout en maintenant la respiration
vous avez également cette possibilité de
faire sur les bras pour durcir
l'exercice
vous maintenez en position de chaque
côté alors j'espère que vous allez bien
suivi et surtout le petit bonus une fête
toujours vos exercices en prenant
conscience de ce que vous faites
visualisez le mouvement de votre corps
le muscle qui se contracte la
respiration
voilà comme on apprend sophrologie cette
efficacité sera d'autant plus productive
au niveau de votre musculature
donc voilà n'oubliez pas et puis
j'espère que ces conseils vous ont servi
et je vous dis à bientôt